all right it's time to get
cooking in the nanny bubby's kitchen
today she's making a delicious
breakfast dish for dinner it's called
shakshouka
nanny bubby is joining us now to show us
how to make it hello happy friday
oh happy friday to you so i want to tell
you how i can make your
thursday very very happy your thursday
night especially when your children get
a little bit older so nanny bubby's
house
every thursday night is breakfast
for dinner how do you like that i love
you for your
yes and so for your children like they
like as they get older
friday is always like a test day
math exam spelling test whatever and a
lot of anxiety
comes with a thursday night but when
they get in the car if you can remind
them it's breakfast for dinner tonight
what do you want
and they can do waffles to pancakes to
your husband
and you say shakshukan a lot of children
love shakshuka
so this is how it starts and you can
freeze this and just throw it down
and make it for dinner so here we go i
started with if you can see i had to
soften these before you got here
i started with onions and peppers and
garlic
they're nice and soft and then i'm gonna
put in two cans
of organic fire roasted diced tomatoes
there we go
right into here and we're gonna cook
this
down until it starts to thicken
now we're going to add we've already
already added a lot of salt to make it
start to
tenderize and cook down and now we're
going to add
paprika can you see that teaspoon
cumin and you know red pepper flakes
quarter of a teaspoon more or less
depending on your taste
we're going to take all that and just
dump it right in
and at this point you're going to set it
aside and let it
cook and thicket okay so
because we have the magic of television
here we need to set that aside
and i have one that has already been
thickened
so at this point what we're going to do
with this is we are going to sorry i
gotta get a little towel
here because i got it all over my hands
what we're gonna do
here here we go back in the game
is as this heats up we're going to take
our greens and these this is straight
from nanny bubby's
uh garden we've got kale we've got
collard greens and a little bit of
spinach
and you put this in at the very end and
you wilt it boy i'm throwing things all
over this kitchen are you seeing how
messy i'm being here
lindsay i'm just it's hidden it looks
really clean from our perspective
i'm just swapping it in here i don't
know what's happened to me in my own
kitchen i tell you what
okay so there you go and as this heats
up it just starts to will
put a little bit more in like so
and then in order to keep this you know
when you cook with tomatoes
it gets very acidy and the recipe
originally called for
uh sugar but i don't use sugar because
you know me and sugar i don't like it
but i am using
coconut yogurt and i'm putting in two
heaping tablespoons of that
and that will keep this from getting
very um
uh acidy and it sweetens it up just
enough
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to make a well
and we're going to do that well with
this right here and we're going to crack
eggs and we're going to poach these eggs
if you can see
here we go sloppy again one
and another one
whoops there we go i wish i remembered a
trial that's
talent yeah julia child had this down i
am not so good let me tell you and
another one
so at this point so actually i usually
put about six to nine eggs in my
shakshouka
and you can do one or two things you can
either take this
and you can cover it like you would
fried eggs and that
you know there's a covering on the top
if you just cover it
or you can take it and you can put it in
the broiler and let it broil
which is what i just did so if you
follow me over to the chapman
oven here okay let me get this stop and
we're gonna open this up and i'll show
you how beautiful this is
it got a little bit brown also i forgot
to mention that you're also going to
throw feta cheese over the top before
you put it into the broiler
so look at that yeah and so
you see this the eggs are right here yep
there's the eggs
and then just to give it a little color
you're going to sprinkle because
something always looks beautiful
out of the oven when you throw the
parsley on it and that my friend
is how you make this beautiful shakshuka
and right here you can see there's
five eggs right and you just dip in let
me grab this
this right here ten seconds and you just
pull up the eggs and there you have it
that looks so
good and i feel like i could do that
right rocky rocky and we're drooling
watching this
oh i love yes yes yes i love that and
can i just
do it yes i have a free gift for all of
our listeners
uh nannybubby.com spices 19 essential
herbs and spices that you need to have
for your kitchen oh
i love it thanks guys thank you so much
guys check out nanny bobby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com
we also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment
rocky